IKAI LAN: Hey, guys.
Welcome to another edition of
YouTube Developers Live.
We're here in York City
in the studio.
We have Mark and Sandeep.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Hi, guys.
IKAI LAN: They're here from
BuzzFeed, and they're going to
talk to us about using BuzzFeed
in their mobile
application.
So first off, before we get
started, why don't we go ahead
and tell people what
BuzzFeed is.
MARK SHUSTER: So, BuzzFeed is
the best place on the internet
to get new, irreverent,
breaking, and viral content,
and then share it with
your friends.
IKAI LAN: Best place?
MARK SHUSTER: Absolutely.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: And it's
full of cute cats.
MARK SHUSTER: And corgis.
IKAI LAN: What makes
it the best place?
MARK SHUSTER: We have a big
editorial staff that's out
there combing the internet for
the best content, and putting
it together in a way that makes
you want to read it,
makes you want to share
it with your friends.
We've kind of taken it
to a whole new level.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: And we have
the best users who are
sharing it across the web.
IKAI LAN: The best users.
You hear that?
If you're using BuzzFeed,
you're the best users.
In the words of Mark
and Sandeep.
MARK SHUSTER: Absolutely.
IKAI LAN: So tell us what you
guys do for BuzzFeed.
MARK SHUSTER: So I'm
a senior designer.
I work primarily on our mobile
products across all platforms.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: And I'm
the director of mobile
technology.
As such, I lead the
mobile apps team.
IKAI LAN: So if you haven't
gotten the hint yet, this is a
show about mobile.
So being that it is a show about
mobile, why don't you go
ahead and show us the
mobile application?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Certainly.
It's an awesome app.
IKAI LAN: Ahh, it's
a praying mantis!
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Sorry.
[INAUDIBLE].
Here's our YouTube
integration.
IKAI LAN: Your YouTube
integration is a mantis?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Yes.
It's a true fact about praying
mantis by Ze Frank.
IKAI LAN: OK.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: It's in
fullscreen, so let's go back
and see how this came up.
IKAI LAN: So where are we now?
What are we looking at here?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: This
is a Buzz page.
MARK SHUSTER: An article.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI:
An article.
It's from Ze Frank.
And it's about the true
facts about mantis.
And we have an embedded
YouTube video.
However, the web view is
displaying an image, and as
the user taps, we intercept the
tap and launch the YouTube
player in the app.
So this provides a seamless
integration to the user, and
they can share this video,
email their friends,
or tweet about it.
MARK SHUSTER: So outside of Buzz
pages specifically, you
can see that this
is the overall
architecture of our app.
You can find our main
feed, essentially--
our newest content--
on the home screen.
Our various sections and
verticals that we've launched
in the last year.
We have almost 11 of
them at this point.
If you're interested in
politics, technology, food.
We even have an animals
vertical.
If all you want to do is look
at cute animals all day, you
can do that, too.
You as a user can go on and
react to content with your
favorite reaction.
If you think it's LOL, if you
think it's a fail, win, if you
just can't believe
it and it's OMG.
You can see content sort
of that way as well.
And then you can see what's hot,
on BuzzFeed and on the
web with our partners online.
We're partnered with dozens
of websites that give us
analytics, and we link
out to them as well.
IKAI LAN: So you guys didn't
start out as a mobile app, if
I'm not mistaken.
You guys started
out on the web.
So what were some of the
motivations of building a
mobile application?
Now, this might seem kind of
silly, only because it seems
like the thing that
everyone's doing.
But usually, it's a good idea
to have a very good
reason for doing so.
MARK SHUSTER: Absolutely.
BuzzFeed started as a community
based website, and
we wanted to go where
our users were.
A lot of our really heavy
users are on the
site all the time.
They're digging through content,
they're reacting and
sharing content.
And the mobile experience
is just a more intimate
experience where they can have
that interaction in the palm
of their hand, and very easily
be able to find the things
that they're interested in.
So we wanted to branch out onto
where our users were, and
give them the tools that they
need to kind of enjoy our
content the best.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Plus, it
passes the one minute test.
Say you're in a meeting,
and you're bored.
You launch the app, and you
can see the cute cats.
MARK SHUSTER: Not that we
encourage looking at cute cats
during business meetings, but
you can with BuzzFeed.
IKAI LAN: And do you guys
ever do this at
your meetings at BuzzFeed?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Yes.
MARK SHUSTER: It's part of our
job, actually, to look at cute
animals during meetings.
IKAI LAN: So how long has the
mobile app been out there?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: I'd say
it's been out there
for two years now.
IKAI LAN: For two years.
And you launched on iOS first,
and the Android version's been
out for how long?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: A year
and a half to two.
IKAI LAN: What are your primary
learnings after
launching a mobile application
in how your users differ in
web and mobile usage?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: We found
that the mobile app's users
are always on the app.
They browse through the content
more than they browse
through our site.
MARK SHUSTER: Right.
Typical BuzzFeed users often
come to BuzzFeed when they're
linked in from Facebook or
Twitter, and they might not be
familiar with BuzzFeed.
IKAI LAN: This is
BuzzFeed web.
MARK SHUSTER: Yeah.
They'll be linked--
maybe they're on their phone,
looking at Facebook, and
they'll be linked out onto
the BuzzFeed website.
And they'll get their content,
but they might not stick with
BuzzFeed as a site.
The difference, I think, in our
user base is that you have
these really dedicated users who
are using the app that are
firing it up multiple
times a day.
They're digging through feeds
and feeds of content.
And then they find the articles
that interest them.
Where essentially, it's the
opposite, where you have
somebody that comes and sees an
article first, rather than
our great lists of content.
And then we need to encourage
those people to either use the
app or engage more with our
mobile web content.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Exactly.
They're more engaged
on the app.
MARK SHUSTER: Absolutely.
They're sharing more, they're
reacting more, they're more
engaged with the content
that we're producing.
IKAI LAN: Do you notice any
major classes of users?
For instance, you guys
have mentioned
the very heavy users.
But beyond the heavy users, are
there typical classes that
you would put them into?
Like, the top three
or four buckets?
MARK SHUSTER: I can try.
No, I mean, I think you have--
as far as app users, I think,
there are people that are
going to react to a lot of
stuff, and maybe aren't going
to be as inclined to share
with other people.
And there's a lot of people
that are just looking for
things that kind of
represent them.
If they're really into animals,
they'll find the best
animals posts, and then they'll
have to show it to
their friends.
They'll have to show it.
And those people will
just share a lot.
And then there are people that
are going to have their
favorite types of content.
They're going to look at just
tech posts, or just politics.
We have a great politics section
that's become really
big recently.
And people can use the app and
just look at politics content,
and they can just use that as
a new vector of obtaining
information about politics.
So we want you to share, and
we want you to react and
engage, but really, we also want
you to be able to get the
kind of experience that you
want with the application
regardless.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Yes.
We do have casual users
who come to the
app through the content.
Either they saw it on the web,
or email link, or tweet.
It's not just for
the heavy users.
IKAI LAN: I think that's the
bucket that I fall into,
because when I use BuzzFeed,
if I'm in line at the bank,
and there's no one to talk
to, my first inkling--
I'm different from most people
in that I will talk to random
people on the street.
And this is very awkward
for many people.
But if there's no one to talk
to, I'll pull it out and I'll
look for a funny cat
picture to save and
send out for later.
So on that note, what types of
analytics do you guys do, and
what are your most important
metrics?
At least on mobile.
And maybe if you can share
anything about the web, that'd
be great for our viewers
as well.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: We use
Google Analytics, obviously.
IKAI LAN: Yay!
I did a show about Google
Analytics a few months ago.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Oh, nice.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK SHUSTER: We have it
integrated in everything.
And I mean, we're interested
in pure how many people are
coming to the website, how many
people are using the app,
but we also want to see how many
pages, how many articles
each of those people are using
to see, is our content
compelling enough?
Do we have more content
available for these people?
Is the content that we're
showing them relevant?
And then on the web side,
especially people who are not
familiar with BuzzFeed, they'll
see links to BuzzFeed
content on Facebook
or Twitter, and
they'll come here.
And are they staying with us,
or are they bouncing off?
So bounce rate's something
really important, because we
want to capture those people,
and we want to encourage them
to use our application.
Because we know that if you're
interested in BuzzFeed
content, you're going
to love our app.
You're going to love the kind of
content that's on the app.
IKAI LAN: So I cannot
stress enough the
importance of using analytics.
I'm not just talking about
Google Analytics.
I mean, using data to
drive your decisions
and your app design.
So I've got to ask
you guys this.
What's something that's happened
in recent history
where you have used analytics
to make a decision about the
product or design or
type of articles--
article selection?
MARK SHUSTER: Well, we get
really granular with analytics
at BuzzFeed.
And we're always trying to
figure out new ways to
encourage people to
share content.
So you might not see it every
time you look at it, but we're
always bucket testing what
kind of designs of share
buttons, where do we put them,
how do we prompt people?
And so just recently, we did a
few AB tests on how buttons
and text labels, and we wanted
to see whether or not we show
you how many other people have
shared this content is going
to encourage you to share
more content.
And we found that some of the
results were surprising.
Some of them weren't.
And based on that, we came
up with a new format for
displaying that information.
IKAI LAN: Anything
you can share?
MARK SHUSTER: Well, we found
that people might not actually
care that there are 2,000 likes
on this article if they
really like it themselves.
And our results were pretty much
inconclusive that just
because there's a count there
doesn't mean it's going to
make you share more.
In fact, it was the opposite.
So we put the text labels back
that tell you what the
button's going to do, and
I think people were more
inclined to click on something
where they knew what the
action was going to result in.
And that was something we
learned through a test that
only took a week.
And it's something that I think
everyone out there can
do with basic analytics
software.
And we have a big data team at
BuzzFeed that is constantly,
constantly crunching numbers
and trying to figure out
what's going viral, and the
best way to share it.
What platforms, and--
IKAI LAN: I'm going to
ask you about that,
just in a little bit.
[INAUDIBLE].
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Yes.
Not on the learning front, but
on the surprising front, ever
since we released the YouTube
integration on Android, the
number of videos played is
actually more than the number
of Facebook shares.
IKAI LAN: Wow.
That's amazing.
And that's very encouraging
to our developers.
So if you guys haven't started
integrating the YouTube API
yet, and you're doing any kind
of video sharing, I highly
encourage you to start looking
at the YouTube SDKs.
So before we go on to technical
section, can you
share anything about the big
picture things that are
happening at BuzzFeed?
MARK SHUSTER: Yeah,
absolutely.
There's a lot going on at
BuzzFeed right now, especially
with BuzzFeed video.
We've hired Ze Frank to be our
VP of video production, and
he's out there creating brand
new custom content and posting
it to YouTube.
IKAI LAN: A little bit of
background for our viewers
that don't know who
Ze Frank is.
MARK SHUSTER: Yeah.
Ze Frank is a great YouTube
personality who's been
creating videos for
a very long time.
He was one of the pioneers
of YouTube video.
And he's really talented
and really funny.
So you should check him out.
You can go to
YouTube.com/BuzzFeed, and see.
We have five channels
already on YouTube.
And we have more than a quarter
million subscribers,
and over 50 million video
views so far.
So we're really excited to use
YouTube to expand our reach,
to not just use YouTube as
a platform for displaying
videos, but also integrate that
social aspect that people
use with commenting and
subscribing and being able to
foster a BuzzFeed video
ecosystem both on YouTube on
BuzzFeed, and kind of
integrate both of
them to each other.
I think that's where we're
definitely moving forward,
too, with how BuzzFeed and video
and YouTube are going to
work in the future.
IKAI LAN: Very, very cool.
Was there anything you wanted
to add to that?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: No.
That's it.
IKAI LAN: Well, I'm going to
ask you the engineering
version of that question,
so get ready.
So on that note, let's start
talking a little bit about
your tech stack.
So tell me, what are
you guys running?
What technology or frameworks
are you guys using?
If you can share that,
of course.
Using some super secret thing.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Yeah,
nothing secretive.
On the apps, we do the
stock Android SDK.
And we have integration tests
that run through each of the
features that we have.
And as an ongoing effort, we are
integrating the bins into
our integration--
the tests and the bins would
be integrated into Jenkins.
Everybody knows what
Jenkins is.
IKAI LAN: I'm familiar
with Jenkins, yeah.
I'm familiar with Jenkins when
it was called Hudson.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: So that's
the next step for us.
And Eclipse as the
SDK standard.
the Git is our version
control.
IKAI LAN: A lot of repos
up on GitHub.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI:
GitHub, yeah.
We go with GitHub.
IKAI LAN: And do you
use anything--
you use Jenkins for builds.
You guys mentioned big data.
What systems you guys use
for data analysis?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Well,
I'm not actually
involved in that, so--
MARK SHUSTER: Our data team is
really huge, and they're using
all kinds of technologies to
kind of pull stuff together.
I know they're building stuff
in Python right now.
They're huge.
I wish I could answer the
question for you, but they're
doing crazy, crazy
number crunching.
We'll have to get them
on a different--
IKAI LAN: You're seeing that
trend a lot now, where you see
big data and analytics teams,
and there's technologies
they're all using.
It's different every single
shop you go to, right?
You're saying you're using
Python, and usually there's
some kind of Hadoop used at
every single shop, but just
how people are using
Hadoop is just--
it's different everywhere
you go.
MARK SHUSTER: It's crazy.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: And it's so
specific, as in the numbers
that come out obviously drive
the [INAUDIBLE] decision.
Probably it's different
at different places.
MARK SHUSTER: And we build their
own tools to display the
results of that on the
front end, too.
And we have developers who
are only looking to do
infographics and infographic
systems, and being able to
display relevant and interesting
charts and graphs
so that we can take all this
data and crunch it down and
display it in a few concise
graphs and snippets.
And that's really valuable to
our development department,
but also to our editorial
team.
They're able to use that to
decide what they want to work
on in the future.
And also our partners and
advertisers, who are able to
get really good data out of our
back end, and use that to
make advertising decisions.
IKAI LAN: So, Sandeep--
hold on, I'm getting a brain
freeze at the moment.
The question I was right
about to ask--
OK, it's this.
So, in working with the YouTube
APIs, you guys are
using the mobile SDK.
What else are you using?
Which of the APIs are
you using, if any?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: We do
Facebook integration, so we
use Facebook SDK big time.
So yeah.
And we use Crittercism to
record all the bugs.
So we get live bug reports
as the app crashes.
We use that particular data--
MARK SHUSTER: Which it
doesn't do a lot.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Yeah,
it doesn't crash--
MARK SHUSTER: But if it does,
we know, so we can fix it.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Yeah.
And that gets added to
the next release.
IKAI LAN: Was there anything
you learned that you would
like to share with other
mobile developers, or
developers working with
the YouTube APIs?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI:
Yes, certainly.
So when we started out, one
YouTube API on Android is well
documented, so we had no issues
integrating the API.
And the other thing was, we
had a choice between using
either the fragment
or the activity.
We chose the activity.
Your mileage might vary.
But there's no difference
between going either way.
One technique we added was we
wanted the user to have a
seamless experience, as in, we
wanted the user not to feel as
though he or she was taken
outside of the app when they
were viewing the video.
So we do this very subtle
fade animation.
And the activity that hosts the
YouTube view also has a
background bitmap, which is a
screenshot of the web view
that they were on.
And it has a slight gradient,
so that the view pops up.
And this is something we
added, and it's pretty
straightforward.
Anyone can add it.
MARK SHUSTER: It gives you
a smooth transition
to the video player.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: Right.
And it gives a good experience
to the user.
MARK SHUSTER: Absolutely.
IKAI LAN: I've seen that
before, where I've seen
applications, and you go to a
new kind of-- it looks like a
new page that's being pushed
on top of the stack, where
it's just a black background.
Whereas I've looked at BuzzFeed,
and I was looking at
this going, how are
they doing this?
How did they put the video on
top of the app like this?
MARK SHUSTER: And I think the
great part about using this in
the future is that
we can add--
right now, we're kind of
Chromeless in that view.
But in the future, we can add
right there, sharing and
reacting, so that as you're
watching the video, you can
still be able to do that kind
of behavior and not have it
interfere with the playing of
the video, but make use of
that black space that would
otherwise appear.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: And we have
great video content, and
we want to slowly expose
that to our users.
And the YouTube API has a
YouTube bitmap or image view
class, which we are
planning to use.
IKAI LAN: And it looks like you
guys are starting to move
into content creation as opposed
to just curation.
So we do have an API to YouTube
Analytics API, which
is something that I would love
to see you guys integrate with
your tool chain at some point.
Because, with the Analytics
API-- and we're starting to do
this too, with our shows--
we're tracking how many minutes
are being watched.
This is something that's very
important to YouTube.
Not just how many views we have,
but how many minutes are
people watching?
I mean, the problem is, if you
watch a video for five seconds
or if you watch a video for
10 minutes, if you're just
counting views, that's just
a view, and it's not quite
meaningful.
MARK SHUSTER: So I'd like to
encourage people out there
that are not using the iframe
API in their mobile websites
to start doing that, because
we actually have an
implementation using the
iframe API, where we're
logging percentages of videos
that are watched.
And it's been really helpful
since switching over to the
iframe API to make sure that
videos are going to display
more or less uniformly over all
platforms, and it's really
saved us a lot of headaches
with dealing with Flash on
older Android devices, dealing
with videos displaying
properly on iOS devices.
So switch over to that
if you haven't yet.
IKAI LAN: So it sounds like the
tips that we have here are
use Analytics, use
the iframe API--
there are a few other ones?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI:
Bitmap background.
IKAI LAN: Bitmap background.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: To give
the smooth animation.
IKAI LAN: So, anything else that
you want to-- anyone's
feedback you would have
for us for the
YouTube API or the SDKs?
Anything you'd like to see?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: The one
thing I'd like to see is a way
to measure, as you
said, the ones
you do with the analytics.
We want to measure how many
seconds, or whether they
played the full video or not.
It would be nice to have that
kind of feedback in either the
fragment or the [INAUDIBLE].
IKAI LAN: I see.
OK, well that's very
good information.
We'll pass that along.
You definitely get that
information when using
Analytics API, but for the
videos that you upload.
So for other people's videos,
it's not going
to be quite as easy.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: So, yeah.
From the app.
Yeah.
MARK SHUSTER: Yeah, I think
we've only really scratched
the surface of what we can
do with YouTube APIs.
And I think that in the future,
integrating more
features that are out there,
like being able to comment,
like, and subscribe to YouTube
channels directly from where
you're watching videos is going
to help bring those
ecosystems together, and create
a better experience for
the user so they can see their
content wherever they want.
IKAI LAN: OK.
Great.
So I'm guessing that after we're
done, this show is going
to be posted to YouTube, and
maybe we can get that into
BuzzFeed, huh?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK SHUSTER: And if you're a
user out there on BuzzFeed,
you can post any video
you create, and try
to make it go viral.
And our editors, if they pick it
up, you can be the next big
BuzzFeed YouTube star.
So who knows?
IKAI LAN: Well, I want to thank
you guys for coming into
our studio today.
It's been an absolute blast.
MARK SHUSTER: Thanks
for having us.
IKAI LAN: Thank you guys for
sharing all this information.
I think this is really good
information that other
developers need to know.
Because some people are starting
to look into this,
and they haven't dived in yet.
And we really like working with
you guys, because you
guys were one of our first
partners to jump in and help
us ship the Android SDK.
So thank you guys for that, and
we look forward to working
with you guys in the future.
MARK SHUSTER: Yeah, we will.
Absolutely.
IKAI LAN: All right.
And one more thing.
I just got the voice
from above.
We are hiring.
Yes.
We are hiring at Google
Developer Relations--
and that was so awkward.
Which was--
go to google.com/jobs, and
you should be able to
find a list of jobs.
I work in Developer Relations,
as do my colleagues.
Sometimes if you watch this
show, you'll see Jeff or
Abraham, or Jarek or Jeremy.
Just check us out.
Take a look to see if it's
something you want to do.
And send us your applications.
What about you guys?
Are you guys hiring?
MARK SHUSTER: We are
always hiring.
IKAI LAN: What are you
guys hiring for?
MARK SHUSTER: We're hiring for
editors, and sales, and also
development.
So check out our job postings.
We're growing.
IKAI LAN: Where are
the jobs at?
Which location?
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI: That's
a good question,
which we don't know.
MARK SHUSTER: You'll have
to check it out.
There's definitely
in New York--
IKAI LAN: Well, where
do you guys work?
MARK SHUSTER: We're here
in New York City.
SANDEEP CHAYAPATHI:
[INAUDIBLE]
job, so you know?
MARK SHUSTER: But also out
in LA, we're opening.
And so BuzzFeed is a great
place to work.
Come work for us.
IKAI LAN: You heard it here.
BuzzFeed is a great
place to work.
Google's kind of cool, too.
We're all right.
So thank you guys very
much for joining us.
And we'll see you
guys next time.
MARK SHUSTER: Have a good one.
IKAI LAN: Bye, guys.